df toi comment tu l'as trouvé les
empires s'amuse bien une fois il ya
qu'une fois à lyon il a fauté bien là
parce qu'il ya c'était une grande salle
et puis il y avait au bistrot est
géniale idée et obi ce lot était pas là
obispo coeur qu'il a la salle est parti
en vrille parce que il n'empêche les
deux enregistré mais si l'autre côté
bonjour et jean-pierre il fait un bras
d'honneur et rentrer dans les coulisses
pendant qu'il y avait un bruit infernal
sanaa
c'est le direct gérard collomb est venu
me voir en misant 20 au maire de lyon sa
mère de louis palmer devient exactement
il est venu voir en images les vallijee
alesi fauves objective à ce poste c'est
vous qui la folie dans les coulisses et
moi je suis arrivé j'ai dit je vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
une belle manière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]